THE REAGANS WERE MARRIED
IN 1952.
NANCY, YOU KNOW,
DEFINITELY CONVINCED RONNIE,
WE'RE--WE ARE HAS-BEENS.
LIKE WE--WE'RE NOT GONNA MAKE IT
IN HOLLYWOOD.
YOU NEED TO BE
MORE CONSERVATIVE.
OW. OH, [bleep].
- YOU OKAY?
WHAT'D YOU DO?
- I'M FINE.
I STABBED MY OWN EYE OUT.
- I DIDN'T LE--
- WHAT?
- HOW DID YOU STAB
YOUR EYE OUT?
- LET'S BE FAMOUS,
YOU KNOW, POLITICALLY,
AND BECOME THE--THE FACES
OF CONSERVATISM?
SHE WAS BASICALLY LIKE
HIS MANAGER.
YOU NEED TO BE THE MOVIE STAR
THAT YOU ARE, ALWAYS SMILE,
AND HOLD YOUR HEAD TO A HALF,
45 DEGREE RIGHT ANGLE.
I THINK SHE, IN HER MIND,
RAN HER OWN STUDIO,
AND--AND--AND SHE HAD
ONE--ONE PLAYER,
AND THAT WAS RONALD REAGAN.
REMEMBER, BUSINETH--BUSINESS.
SO IT WAS 1964.
BARRY GOLDWATER WAS RUNNING
FOR PRESIDENT,
A HYPER-CONSERVATIVE,
A BORING HUMAN BEING.
THEY EMPLOYED RONALD REAGAN,
WHO WAS THIS FAMOUS, GREAT ACTOR
TO GIVE THE SPEECH.
IN THE SPEECH HE SAID YOU CAN
EITHER GO RIGHT OR LEFT.
BUT THAT'S NOT WHAT IT IS,
IT'S EITHER UP OR DOWN.
AND UP, YOU CA--YOU CAN CHOOSE
TO BE UP
TOWARDS INDIVIDUALISM,
OR DOWN
IN THE DEPTHS
OF TOTALITARIANISM.
PEOPLE WERE LIKE,
WOW, I NEED TO WATCH THIS.
HE HAS A CHISELED JAW,
I TRUST HIM.
I LIKE THIS GUY.
AND SO LIKE, THEN HE GOT VERY
POPULAR WITH THE REPUBLICANS.
SO THEY WERE NOT
SUCCESSFUL ACTORS AS ACTORS,
BUT THEY WERE INCREDIBLY
SUCCESSFUL ACTORS
AS POLITICIANS.
AND RONNIE BECAME
THE GOVERNOR OF CALIFORNIA.
NANCY WAS ALWAYS
ABOUT BEING FAMOUS ON ANY LEVEL.
LIKE, IF I'M NOT GOING
TO BE A MOVIE STAR,
I'M GONNA BE, YOU KNOW,
IN THE WHITE HOUSE.